deux coupes faim incriminés dans de
récentes études scientifiques viennent
d'être retirés du marché
une étude montrait que la prise de ces
médicaments pouvaient accroître les
risques d'incident cardiaque
explications gilles marine est eric de
l'agneau c'est à la suite d'une enquête
menée aux états unis sur des accidents
cardiaques et dont les résultats ont été
connus ce week-end que l'agencé
française du médicament décidé de
suspendre la commercialisation des deux
coupes faim produits efficaces pour
maigrir mais dangereux pour le coeur aux
etats unis la food and drug
administration a reçu un certain nombre
de cas d'atteintes des valves cardiaques
parfois sévères chez des patients qui
étaient traités sur une plus ou moins
longue période
vendu sans restriction en amérique
pondérale et l'isoméride était déjà sur
la sellette en france depuis 1995 à la
suite de plusieurs décès la première
prescription était réservé aux seuls
médecins hospitaliers pour une durée
limitée et dans le cas d'obésité sévère
de 400 mille boîtes annuel la
consommation était tombé à 4000 le
laboratoire servier a décidé de retirer
le produit du marché ce qui aurait
finalement peu de conséquences sur les
traitements en cours
il faut surtout pas dire l'âge n'est
plus le médicament c'est c'est terminé
je ne pourrai plus soigné les obèses ou
bien les obèses dr eva c'est terminé on
nous a supprimé libye également
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à grossir et
mourir ça c'est inacceptable parce que
ce n'est pas vrai la palette existante
des programmes diététiques devrait
permettre en effet de pallier à
l'absence de coupe faim le laboratoire
servier lui reprend à zéro
l'étude d'un produit